i used to do it and enjoy the ego
trip you know but i then one day
thought of it i thought but i don't know
i actually
came and that was more than worried
how did that power how did that power
all of a sudden come i've been working
for it for years
now i don't even know how i cut it so i
started
looking backwards so i realized this
good posture concentration
trying to not let there be a gap between
my mind
from there to there and then i try to
slightly
shorten that gap so when i do
that i'm almost saying to my mind
concentrate
so i'm being very strict with myself so
really
that's the way to link it together
when you finally get here you don't
concentrate because you realize it's a
bit like
i've got to take the key off last night
i've slept in it it's almost like
becoming so part of you
you don't think about it what i'd like
to do is um
that the twenty joseph early what might
sound to some of you and probably done
that so many times
think about this look it's the whole
body
the joe is just part of it so
you power the joe
by pulling up there
you power the joe by doing that
then about here you
jump on the drone of a ride
so you it's a bit like jumping on the
bus you know you're static you're
waiting the bus stop jump the bus
so i'm going to go like this so i go
like this
i go like that and about there it is
if it's not but it's the pin about there
it becomes
light so this is the pin
about there you've either got now power
out
let it flow down if you can get to ride
on it mentally
this happens
all right so i i
attached myself to the job
and i went and then it's what we call
spiritual
because you don't you don't
feel the distance you go or where you go
you go
and that's when you become enduro senses
because you become from human to
spiritual
it's not this sort of spiritual but it's
you
ride on the energy
it's only when you it's only when you go
and start thinking well i can do that
then you've actually jumped off the joe
again and you've now
started driving the joe